[Musik]
ja fast drei monate krieg in der ukraine
im osten gehen die extrem kämpfe weiter
zwischen beiden seiten wir wollen uns
heute wieder neue aufnahmen ansehen die
uns erreicht haben die eben
signalisieren und symbolisieren die fand
nicht dort die kämpfe eben geführt
werden als allererstes schauen wir uns
neue aufnahmen an aus der kleinen stadt
bionorica
dort hat die russische armee am 19 mai
versucht den kiosk im netz einen fluss
zu überqueren es ist teilweise gelungen
aber die ukraine haben ihn dort
aufgelauert und haben dort ein absolutes
massaker unter den panzern und natürlich
auch unter den soldaten angerichtet
diese bilder erinnern mich persönlich an
kriegsbeginn kurz vor kiel wir erinnern
uns dort hatten wir diese straßen in der
stadt wo links und rechts über all diese
russischen panzer waren die alle
zerstört wurden das gleiche ist hier
passiert nur eben wir haben keinen keine
stadt sondern wir haben ein wald vor uns
eine kleine dünne waldstraße und wir
sehen einfach mal dutzender zerstörte
russische panzer fahrzeuge hier die wir
sehen uns hier von schwerer artillerie
getroffen wurden und völlig vernichtet
wurden
tote soldaten sind nicht mehr da die
wurden alle mittlerweile von den russen
weggenommen wir wissen dass bei dieser
gescheiterten flussüberquerung um eben
dort einen kessel zu schlagen und ein
kessel herzustellen dass dort mindestens
73 russische fahrzeuge zerstört wurden
und so heißt es aus russischen quellen
500 soldaten der russischen armee ums
leben gekommen sind lediglich 65 haben
diesen massiven angriff überlebt also
wie gesagt ein kleiner waldweg sozusagen
der genommen wurde der aber schon drei
tage vorher von den ukrainern
ausspioniert wurde die hatten dort ja so
speer die sich das angeguckt haben die
gesehen haben wie die russen die brücken
aufgebaut haben diese puncto brücken und
dann im gewartet haben und die
artillerie konnte sich tagelang vorher
darauf einrichten genau diesen weg zu
bombardieren hat das dann getan und wir
sehen wirklich links und rechts dutzende
zerstörte russische fahrzeuge das ganze
wie gesagt einen versuch vom achten und
neunten mal hier einen kessel aufzubauen
und wir sehen uns noch mal die karte im
osten an wir wissen ja dass diese diese
bestrebung diesen osten hier abzuriegeln
eben zuerst in diesem großen großen
kessel der da errichtet werden sollte
der eben 50.000 ukrainer dort gefangen
nehmen sollten gestern sollte das ist
fehlgeschlagen aber wir sehen neue
kessel die ja aufgebaut werden und der
alarm ist sozusagen das jemand ist einer
in der region luhansk lohans ist hier
zum allergrößten teil wir sehen uns hier
bereits besetzt von russland lediglich
fünf prozent sind hier noch frei und
hier sehen wir dass hier ein neuer
vorstoß stattfindet bei der stadt wo
passen diese stadt wurde vor einigen
tagen erobert und seit gestern sehen wir
das hier so ganz kurz wir sehen dass das
ist aus papas nah dass das soziale
zentrum von topas
relativ große stadt die ich auch schon
besucht habe nicht dieses haus aber das
haus gleich am straßen ende
da sehen wir dass die russische armee
sich dadurch bewegt und zwar mit
massiven verbänden da hinten ganz kurz
nochmal eingezeichnet das hier ist das
rathaus von pro partner was man da
hinten sieht da gab es verschiedene
politische treffen an denen ich auch
teilgenommen hat im jahr 2009 10 und
insofern ist das auch ganze verifiziert
also wir sehen das neue aufnahmen sind
auto passen aber was von den russen
erobert wurde und wir sehen dass hier
russische falschen truppen sich massiv
durch die stadt bewegen das ist seit
vorgestern etwa ist das der fall gestern
noch viel mehr wir sehen einen endlosen
konvoi das kommt jeweils aus osten aus
es doch statt run off heißt die stadt
kommt dass hier ein und geht dann durch
die stadt durch und wir wissen jetzt von
sowohl von russischer seite als auch vom
ukrainischen generalstab bestätigt dass
es hier einen durchbruch gehabt ein
durchbruch der front wir zeigen dass
noch einmal bei dem was wir sehen können
hier also passen hinter diesem jahr
leider ein thema versteckt von pathos
und wir sehen hier einen neuen
durchbruch in diese richtung man
versucht also ein kessel aufzubauen um
sie wäre die letzte großstadt im nu ganz
genau gehalten und von den ukrainern
einzukesseln die russen sagen sie wollen
hier ein neues mario pohl szenario
errichten sie wollten also mario pohl
was er eingekesselt wurde dann ja fast
zwei monate belagert wurde und jetzt
schließlich zu 99 prozent erobert wurde
das wollen wir auch ins netz kamen und
es gibt berichte darüber ob die wahr
sind oder propaganda ist nicht klar dass
einige ukrainer und krokant kommandeure
mittlerweile fragen ob sie wäre jetzt
verlassen werden darf um ein zweites
mario pohl zu verhindern das kann
russische propaganda sein das wird seit
gestern diskutiert in verschiedenen
telegramm kann er in jedem fall ist es
ein riesiges problem was hier entsteht
und wie gesagt es ist ein russischer
durchbruch der stattgefunden hat vom
ukrainischen generalstab heute morgen
auch zugegeben mindestens drei orte
westlich von topas nach bodenart und wir
haben dort wie gesagt vorrücken
russischer truppen
die letzte chance eigentlich oder die
hoffnung der ukraine um sich weiter zu
verteidigen um sich auch effektiv zu
verteidigen sind die westlichen waffen
und von denen sind mittlerweile einige
wieder eingetroffen und wir sollen ist
das mal angucken das ist ein so
genanntes dana geschützt eigentlich aus
der tschechoslowakei jetzt aber von
tschechien in die ukraine gegeben und
wir wissen das sind schwere waffen das
sind arterie waffen die eben feuern
können und das besondere an der das
nennt sich ein rad haubitze wir sehen
also die hat hier vier achsen und acht
räder und die kann schnell hin und
herbewegt werden wir sehen jetzt gleich
der schuss der erfolgt und das besondere
ist guck mal hier hin hier sehen wir
gleich wie die alte granate abgefeuert
wurde bzw das um diese beschleunigen
rauskommt und die kann also automatisch
nachgeladen werden dass also ein
wichtiges geschützt mit dem man sich
schnell hin und her bewegen kann
schiessen kann wieder woanders hinfahren
kann und somit der russischen artillerie
ausreichen kann darauf hofft die ukraine
davon braucht sie wesentlich mehr sie
wartet weiter auf die deutsche
panzerhaubitze 2000 die versprochen
wurde gibt es aktuell eine ausbildung
wurde noch nicht geliefert die braucht
die ukraine ukraine dringender denn je
um hier putins vorstoß im osten
aufzuhalten
[Musik]